-Our first guest tonight i
an Emmy-nominated actor
and comedian who you know
from his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
"The Last Man on Earth,"
and the timeless film classi
"MacGruber."
He stars in the animated serie
"The Great North,"
which premieres
Sunday night on Fox.
Please welcome back to the sho
our very good friend Will Forte.
How are you, Will?
-I'm doing great.
-How are you, Seth?
-I'm doing wonderful, as well.
Even better seeing you.
And you just had a birthday,
my friend.
You just turned 50,
and your fiancée --
your lovely fiancée --
planned a scavenger hunt
for you,
which is such a nice thing to do
in a time where people
obviously cannot have the
parties they would like to do.
-Yes, it was --
It was a total surprise.
And you know, it's been --
it was during COVID.
This was June, so COVID
had made everyone kind of
live in isolation.
So we went around to
these different stops
and socially distanced,
so it was all very safe.
But what she did was she had
different face masks made
with different versions
of my face.
So, like, this was one of them
-[ Laughs ]
Fully bearded.
-Uh-huh.
-And then there was
just mustache.
-Right.
-That's another one.
-That's really good.
-But then the real hit
was the half-and-half.
[ Laughter ]
On Earth.
-She's very -- She's very luck
to be marrying a man
who once did that to his face.
-No, she thanks her
lucky stars every day.
-And you both have a lot
to thank, as well,
because you're
about to be a dad.
Very quickly.
Within a month or so, right?
-We are -- Yes.
Yeah, we got engaged
a year ago Christmas,
and we thought
we'd get married first.
But then COVID
delayed our plans,
so we thought,
"Okay, we'll just..."
Then, on Father's Day,
I actually found out
that we were pregnant.
It was very...
Or that she was pregnant,
I guess I could say.
I know biology.
So, you know,
we've been preparing
since that day.
And then a couple --
We thought, "Okay,
we're doing pretty good."
You never feel probably like
you're totally ready for it.
This is my first kid,
so I don't know.
But we thought, "Okay, we're
doing pretty good here."
And then, a couple days ago,
she got this call
from the hospital
that said, "Oh, you know how
several times, you've been tol
that your insurance
is going to work here?
Oh, we're now telling you
that it's not.
Now we're going
the other way on that."
-[ Chuckles ]
-So it's not
the thing you want to hear
three weeks before giving birth.
So we got -- We figured ou
our plan,
which is we're going to Vega
and we are getting a quick -
we're getting quickly married.
-[ Laughs ]
-I love it.
This is sort of
an insurance-inspired weddin
in Vegas.
-It's the storybook marriage
that I always wanted.
So I looked up this place,
and it says there are no vows.
There's a minister
you got to give 60 bucks to.
Cash. It's got to be cash.
-[ Chuckles ]
-And you go through --
What it seems like to me i
that you just kind of drive up
to what looks like
a fast-food restaurant
drive-through,
and some guy just
looks into your car
and looks you over a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
And just,
"Alright, you're married,"
and then that's it.
-Wow.
He has to see true love,
and then if he sees it,
you're married.
-Exactly, exactly.
-You guys took a step, which
I think is an important step
before having a baby,
which is you guys have a dog
Which you gave
a beautiful name to,
that, unfortunately now that
you've given it to your dog,
you won't be able
to give it to your daughter.
What's your dog's name?
-Our dog is named Mudbutt.
We don't need it,
'cause our daughter,
we're probably gonna name
Kia -- Kia Forte.
[ Laughter ]
It's still in the mix, but we're
probably not going with Kia.
But, yeah, Mudbutt is
our little COVID puppy,
who has grown into a devil
basically.
[ Laughter ]
It's like he is just
a little Damien "Omen" dog
He eats all his toys whole
Like, I'll pick up his poops
and there are full
just totally unchewed-on toys.
Just pristine toys.
I can almost put them
back in the box and
return them at a store.
-And this is a very harrowin
photo I'm going to show
of something you found
your dog chewing on.
-Oh, yeah. So, I was --
I was sitting by the couch
and something smelled
very badly.
And I was like, "Did somebod
barf under one of these cushions
and leave it there for a month
and then pour water on it
and leave that for a month?"
-[ Laughs ]
-And then I realized -- I looked
over a couple feet away,
and I said, "oh, no, that'
the fricking old deer leg
that Mudbutt dragged in
from God knows where."
-This is a full deer leg!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's a hoof or a "hoofe,"
depending on if you're
Australian or something.
[ Laughter ]
But that's a haunting thing.
Haunting.
-It scared me.
It was scary.
And then I looked around,
I was thinking, "Okay, well,
that's got to be connected
to, you know,
more parts of the deer."
And I couldn't find
the other deer there.
But, yeah, it's scary,
'cause you're like,
"Is my dog doing
satanic rituals?"
-Well, I'm so excited, one, that
you're going to get married.
I'm so excited, two, that you're
going to have a baby.
And I feel terrible saying this,
I may be most excited,
that I believe,
potentially, in June
you're going to start filmin
the "MacGruber" TV show.
-That is correct.
June is when the start dat
is supposed to be.
-And then you'll be going
back to Albuquerque,
where you shot the film.
-Yes.
-And you know, I think
there are a group of fans
out there
who are more excited about thi
than anything.
Could you give us a taste?
Is there any dialogue you coul
read us from one of the scripts?
-I went through today
with John and Jorma
because we wanted to be
a little classier
with this next iteration
of "MacGruber."
-Yes, now it's going to be
prestige television.
-Yeah, so, basically what --
All you need to know for thi
is that Kristen Wiig's
character, Vicki,
we used to be married.
And since then,
we are not married anymore
and she is now with this guy
named Colonel Fasoos,
who's my commanding officer.
And we've been at each other's
throats the whole series.
And this is how
I make up to him.
This is my speech in which I
make good with him, I apologize.
This is me now as MacGruber,
with my MacGruber
reading glasses on.
Look, I owe you a huge apology
I am so sorry.
No, no, no, no, no,
I need to say this.
I've called you so many
nasty things behind your back.
Called you a dirty diaper with
arms, legs, and half a brain
I called you
a [Bleep] [Bleep] face.
I said you're a mother[Bleep
[Bleep] nose face,
[Bleep] [Bleep] tool,
[Bleep]-ass butt wipe,
[Bleep] little bitch,
piece of [Bleep],
piece of [Bleep].
Put them together, and calle
you a piece of [Bleep].
I called you all that stuff,
but I was wrong.
Because you're not
a piece of [Bleep].
You're a piece-of-[Bleep]
friend.
[ Laughter ]
And I mean that.
So, that's the softer MacGrube
I'm going for.
-I can't wait, buddy.
I can't wait for everythin
that's coming up for you.
It is always a pure deligh
to see you.
Thanks so much for being here.
-I love you and miss you.
-I love you, too.
"The Great North" premiere
Sunday, February 14th, on Fox.